[Music]
the unmanned aerial vehicle project at X
which we call wing has is its aspiration
to remove the bulk of the remaining
friction from how we move physical
things around in the physical world
particularly the so-called last mile
problem if you look at the history of
how physical things have been moved
around in the physical world every time
a chunk of the remaining friction was
removed from that process both planes
trains the automobile the Pony Express
the mail system every one of these
things as we got more organized and
removed cost and complexity from how
physical things got moved around in the
world the world became so different that
it was impossible beforehand to even
predict how different and how much
better would be on the other side of
that introduction we take for granted
the remaining friction as though it's
natural and will continue forever if you
could have anything that would fit in a
bread box brought to you within one or
two minutes you still have to pay for
the thing that's in the bread box but it
could be brought to you merely for free
then our world would be radically
different those batteries that are
sitting in a drawer in your house or
apartment right now discharging you have
those batteries you're wasting the
planet because you think you might need
a few of those batteries before they
fully discharged on some Christmas
morning or something but if you believed
you could have any batteries any shape
to battery you want just in the moment
you need it you wouldn't bother holding
all those batteries you probably have a
hammer in your house or apartment why do
you have that hammer you almost never
use it and we all have to have a hammer
for the occasional moment when we want
the hammer but we could probably share
one hammer around 10 cm
one of us think how much richer the
world would be if we could have that how
are we going to make it so that you
could have the hammer just appear within
a moment or two when you want it you say
I want a hammer you get a cup of coffee
at the most and the hammer is there and
our proposal for how to do that is that
you can make small vehicles that fly
through the air quietly and very safely
and bring to you whatever you want our
prediction is that at first society will
adopt these for the use of delivering
food food is something that almost
everybody uses and that they use on a
very regular basis there's already a
very robust food delivery market and
people express an interest in having a
lot more delivered to them with respect
to food so that is likely to be the
early adoption of this technology but
the long run promise of being able to
move things around inside of cities and
the suburban areas in particular without
having to create more traffic congestion
without the carbon footprint that comes
from large trucks moving packages around
without the sound and safety problems
produced by large trucks moving around
our city all of those problems can be
solved by flying what you want what you
need right now to you through the air
we're public about the fact that we did
more than a thousand flights last year
in wing and I would like to see at least
a hundred times that many this year and
one hundred times as many of the year
after that and and I don't think that
that at all out of the question there
are regulatory conversations to be had
and demonstrations of safety to be
proven as we step through this process
in the United States and in other
countries and it's important that we
push hard on the technology but also
work thoughtfully and responsibly with
the regulators to demonstrate the safety
and to build their confidence in what
we're doing as we take each incremental
[Music]